- Yo, what up, what up, vlog.
Very special episode of DailyShe.
The incredible women that are
the foundation at VaynerMedia.
I think you're gonna
enjoy this little mix up,
a little twist up, a
little different angle,
of what we do here.
Recognizing some of the incredible people.
On this very special day.
I hope you enjoy,
this special episode of DailyShe.
(upbeat techno music)
- My name is Tatiana.
Tatiana Urriaga.
I am a director of account strategy.
Here at VaynerMedia.
- Hi, good morning.
I'm Mayumi Tatsuta.
And I'm group creative director.
- Hi, I'm Jen Bang.
I'm a business operations manager.
- I'm Caitlin Kean.
Associate creative director.
- The best part about my job.
And what I do everyday,
is the fact that I get to--
if I do it right,
I get to cultivate people's talents.
And ensure their success.
Not just here at Vayner.
But also outside of here,
beyond here for the
longevity of their career.
I think what's really
nice about this idea,
and this type of work is that, you know,
it really encourages the
brand to have such an honest,
conversation with the audience.
So, it seems so authentic.
It is authentic.
But, what's also great,
like this is the type of work
that is most powerful, right.
Because we are igniting a conversation.
We're sparking conversation
that has to be had,
within this audience, within our industry,
within this generation.
- Being exposed to so many people,
who have not so hidden talents,
really great strengths and
weaknesses that help you grow,
and challenge yourselves as well.
And so its just been a
personal journey of growth.
And professional too.
- I love the fact that
the name on the door,
that we walk through every single day,
I love the stuff that he says,
like who gives a fuck, it
does not fucking matter,
don't worry about what they say.
There will always be haters.
Whether it's your parent's who
don't believe in what you do.
Your friends, cultural
norms, who gives a fuck.
If you love what you do, just
walk through those doors,
every single day and own it.
It really does not matter.
We just have to stop this whole like,
they might be thinking this,
they might be saying that.
Who cares.
It really doesn't matter.
All that matter's is that
you believe in what you do.
And that you go for it.
And that you feel like
you're giving your best,
every single day.
- My badass female role
model is Amelia Earhart.
When people said to her,
hey you can't fly across
the Atlantic solo.
She was like, hey hold on hold my beer.
- Besides Oprah and my mom.
Is Issa Rae.
She's just an awesome
creative, black creative,
and I just really look up to her.
What she's doing for TV and
just for people like me.
- My mom because she taught me everything,
and taught me to be a confident woman.
That doesn't take shit from anybody.
- One who is at Vayner is Natalie Carey.
Natalie is all of the organization,
that I would want to have in my life.
But also just brings incredible
empathy to every team,
that she's ever worked on.
And I admire her immensely for that.
- The woman who gave me
the job at VaynerMedia,
Romy Nehme.
She was the first person to believe in me,
and my potential, and give
me a shot in strategy.
- Learn how to self promote
and know that it's okay.
Because you have to undo all the training,
that you've had in school.
Where you raise your hand,
wait to get called on,
and then get to speak.
So, just having to undo all that training.
Knowing that it's okay
to speak for yourself.
And speak on behalf of others,
advocate for them as well,
is something that I've
learned while being at Vayner.
And would love to share with everyone too.
- [Interviewer] How did
you get to that place?
And get so confident.
Start to undo that good
girl behavior training.
- I guess it's when you're
towing that line between,
what's expected of me
and what is truly me.
And being able to better understand,
you know what am I doing for myself.
How am I supposed to make
this job work for me.
Like, Mayumi was just saying
because I had to flip,
that mentality of me being a worker.
Because that's sort of
how I was all my life.
And having to move up and
become more or a managerial,
person meant that I had
to take that next step.
And also show the way for others as well.
- The advice I give to women
starting off in this business,
right now.
Even when you are on staff.
Act like a freelancer or
think like a freelancer.
Don't think that you work for the company.
Make the company work for you.
You're surrounded, hopefully
by some of the most talented,
smartest people in this
business and this industry.
You're surrounded by
tools, resources, you know,
take all that, grasp all that,
and make opportunities for yourself.
Don't ever think that you're
working for this company,
Oh I have a job I wear this--
no make the company work for you.
- It's like, it's an accountability thing.
It's about being responsible.
And wherever you are
owning those opportunities.
And owning that and taking responsibility,
for your own success.
And for the success of the team.
And so, I would say my
advice is to not apologize.
And to own the position that you're in.
And find that success
and figure things out,
for yourself and make those inroads,
and advocate for yourself.
And manage up, manage
down, manage side to side.
In every way it's really
about being accountable.
And taking responsibility for,
for where you are and the
opportunities you have.
And your success.
- I realize now that my--
the perspective that I
bring to the job everyday,
is what sets me apart.
And is my strength.
It's like the more you
can tap into who you are,
the more specific the work is.
And then you're gonna drive
those business results,
because it's gonna resonate.
So, don't be afraid to really
let that show up in a meeting,
with your colleagues.
And don't be polite, if
you're not polite, you know.
But yeah, keep it professional.
But, yeah really bringing that
whole self to work everyday.
I think just makes the work better.
- Be so good, they can't ignore you.
So I feel like, the work
and the hustle piece for me,
is like, I'm gonna be so good at my job,
that it doesn't matter.
And really focusing on the objectivity,
of being good and being successful
and putting the work in.
And that's like the accountability piece.
Be so good that it doesn't matter.
And focusing on your skillset
and being successful.
And putting the work in.
Is the advice I would give.
- The best piece of advice was
actually from an Instagram,
post from K-Pop,
here at VaynerExperience.
She said, she doesn't do
anything for the fame,
she shows it all through her actions.
So stop talking and start doing, shit.
So, yeah.
- The best piece of advice
I've ever received is,
always negotiate your salary
because no one's gonna,
to watch for how much money
you make except for you.
- Stop comparing yourself to others.
You're on your own journey
and it might take unexpected,
roads, but you'll eventually get there.
- Hey, I'm so glad to
be a female leader here,
at VaynerMedia.
I'm proud of the fact that
this is a video that's,
showcasing some of our
amazing female talent.
And male talent, too.
We've got a 50, 50 split here at Vayner.
And it's something that we are proud of.
We showcase every single day.
So, rock on.
Thanks for watching.
And we'll see ya.
(upbeat techno music)